joining us on the line is Glenn Beck CEO
of the blaze host of Glenn radio Glenn
CV Glenn Beck podcast basically anything
named after Glenn Beck is probably
hosted by Glenn Beck is a pretty good
bet he also has a brand new book out it
is called arguing with social as well
congratulations Glenn you won the
argument
Bernie dropped out today thank you good
timing on that what do you make no
geriatric communist leaving the race I
am I'm sending him a copy of the book
he's got plenty of time to read it now
it is it's amazing to me how the the
extreme agent are doing so well in the
Democratic Party I don't think I don't
think Biden is gonna end up being the
guy cuz I think he's fading really
really fast and I think they're just
gonna be there's gonna be some there's
gonna be somebody that goes come on guys
I mean listen to him he doesn't even
know where he's at right now we we can't
have him run for Brit
it's possible they they could have a
zoom convention and it's possible that
he just like my grandparents just can't
Skype in he's just trying to zoom in and
he's like hitting the button totally Joe
Biden tank that into the Pelican Bay
chicken the only person who can I guess
you're the presidential candidate so no
Bernie but what led to Bernie's downfall
here because you and I had discussed
weeks ago the the sort of going notion
that after Bernie had tied in Iowa one
in New Hampshire one in Nevada that he
was the guy going forward and then the
Democratic Party really consolidate
around Biden after South Carolina where
he won a sweeping victory so what
happened here because Bernie I've been
told by Bernie had created an historic
movement and then lost to a person who
is not actually sentient so what exactly
happened here mm-hmm I think what
happened was they saw themselves losing
horribly with with an avowed socialist a
guy who was defending the Castros and
and Russia and everything else and they
realized we cannot go forward with this
guy or it will be a historic loss and
they just all kind of rallied the wagons
and circled the wagons around Biden I've
never seen anything in American politics
like it it was
ordinary what they did to make sure that
he was not the candidate it was pretty
incredible now that the question going
forward is whether the Democratic Party
is still Bernie's party meaning that
Biden was sort of the last gasp it can't
be this geriatric horrifying nasty
communist it's got maybe if we put a
nicer face on it next time around it's
somebody who's less off-putting but but
similarly Wilde left Elizabeth Warren
tried that for a little while and then
it turned out that she flamed out when
she tried to actually put meat on the
bones of socialism as it turns out
socialism only can be supported via the
bones but it's but well do you think
that the future of the Democratic Party
looks less like Biden and more like
Bernie yes not not physically like
Bernie I think it looks more like a city
I think you're going to see especially I
mean then when when I was writing the
book I thought we were going to be
talking about the the primaries and you
know the difference between the free
market and socialism well we're talking
about coronavirus but what they're still
talking about in Washington is a free
market or socialism all of the things
that Bernie had on his dream list is
being put on the dream list of all of
these bailouts what the Fed is doing is
the modern monetary theory so we're
moving in this direction and I I think
Bernie Sanders was more like Barry
Goldwater I think you're going to see
the loss of the you know Bernie Sanders
now but it was it was imprinted on the
hearts of a lot of people that grew up
with their first memory being September
11th when the markets crashed and
everybody was freaking out then the next
big crisis was Oh 8 and the bank's
crashed and their parents lost all their
money and now this one this looks if you
were born around the turn of the century
this looks like a very unstable system
that just destroys people and the people
of the top just get more power and more
money that's who that's who we have to
reach out to and say look what every bit
of your experience is not what the free
market really is this is not the free
market and it hasn't been like this
until we really started tinkering with
everything Glenn this is what scares me
so much about what's going
currently is you know aside from the
threat of the pandemic itself and how
many people are going to die what what
scares me long term for the politics of
the United States is that you know I had
Andrew yang on my Sunday special and
very nice guy but we were talking
universal basic income and his basic
thesis is the technology was gonna put
millions and millions of people out of
work and then you needed to support them
via the government I said well there's
not a lot of evidence of that we got a
three point five percent unemployment
rate more jobs open than candidates
looking for the jobs well one way that
you can achieve the the sort of
universal basic income idea pretty
quickly is to forcibly throw thirty
million people out of work over the
course of one month by completely
shutting down the American economy and
then turning around and blaming
capitalism this was a government induced
economic coma and I'm not saying that it
wasn't necessary may very well turn out
to be that it was necessary in the time
that was but I think a lot of people are
gonna take away from that well if my job
went away and then doesn't come back
because most of the jobs that have been
going away our blue-collar mid to low
pay jobs that what choice do I have
other than to go to the government and
ask them to create some sort of wealth
tax on the wealthy and completely
destroy the foundations of capitalism on
the back of a government induced
economic disaster I have to tell you one
of the chapters in the book Ben is about
technology
a massive disruption of jobs and
technology getting in bed with the
government and the government using
universal basic income and also
modern monetary monetary theory mulai
didn't say it was coronavirus that's
what's just happened and it is a freight
train that is coming down at us and if
we are not informed if we don't know
what modern monetary theory is if we
don't know what universal basic income
really is it's going to be put in just
like FDR did all kinds of stuff when
people are freaking out and they're
hungry you can do anything anything but
the long-term effects of this are
disastrous for the free market yeah
Glenn I could see the aftermath depends
I meant going a couple of ways one could
be that people are so fed up with being
cooped in their houses that the glories
of socialism have brought
with them you know us actually living in
basically army barracks or restricted to
quarters and and so at the end of this
were like okay no socialism and also I
want to leave my house so if we were
going to get all of the you know
government largesse and it was going to
be connected with all so you can never
leave your house again and you're locked
in here with your three children then
perhaps at the end of this there's
actually a libertarian moment where we
all go okay well I need the government's
leave me the hell alone now
or you could conversely see what you're
talking about particularly if there's a
long lasting recession out of this which
way do you think that's going to go gosh
man I would love to tell you that I
think it's going to go a happy way but I
could see it the case for both I could
see it going when we are finally let out
that the American spirit is just on fire
and we produce more than we've produced
in a very long time
but I also think that there's a lot of
people including the media that want
this president to fail and love their
love of country is far less than their
hatred for Donald Trump and it's almost
as if they're rooting for this to be
going on and misery to be you know
stacked up upon misery upon misery upon
misery that I could see us going the
opposite direction as well because I
think there are those people that want
this to this coronavirus to be
successful at the expense of the country
being successful you know III think
there are a lot of people who would like
to see the impact of the corner of Isis
particularly economic sphere magnified
and I don't think anybody wants to see
lots of people die but I think that if
they if with what people get out of this
is a giant growth of government I think
a lot of people will be happy with that
growth of government when it comes to
the actual pandemic Glenn how do we get
out of this because right now the data
are just not sufficient we don't know
anything and it's it's driving me up a
wall because at the same time we're
being told trust the experts the experts
are not providing us any level of
transparency into how they're thinking
about this sort of stuff they like when
the White House released its numbers
when they said 100,000 to 240,000 people
are gonna die they didn't give us a
period a time period then give us the
factorial inputs and
the studies just keep being reduced so
now we have today the IMA chi model
which has reduced the number of expected
deaths down over the course of five days
from 93 thousand all the way down to
sixty thousand so what exactly changed
they won't really say because they can't
really say instead they're just sort of
saying well it looks like staying at
home is working at the same time I don't
know that anyone in the government has
actually set up a plan for us getting
back to work so what do you think this
looks like and how do we get out of it
you know it's funny Ben because I was
just talking about this on my show today
that the government has not given us a
trip wire from the very beginning I've
been asking what is the trip wire what
are the factors that are saying that we
need to close schools that we need to
close businesses that we have to close
what are those what are those trip wires
and I couldn't get anyone in Washington
to tell me what they are
well I'm fine myself in exactly the same
place somebody's making a decision on
whether we open this country or not can
you tell us what it is because of the
way I think this should have been done
is the trip wires they should have said
look if we have this kind of spread with
these kinds of numbers and the beds in
the hospital are at this rate we think
that schools should close we think that
and then you should have to a volunteer
to do those in your own community
because in my community my hospital
rates are not there the the different
things that are happening in New York
are not happening here but at least tell
me how you're making these decisions and
no one is telling us what is the
president looking for to happen so we
can get out it is it's it's it's like a
prison sentence that could end at any
time or could last forever that would I
own cruel and unusual punishment it is
it is pretty wild especially because
again some of the estimates that are
being put forward what when doctor foul
Qi said well we have to wait until we
have no deaths and I just thought to
myself well you like there's no with
this is country 330 million people what
it would it's talking about right now
there's not gonna come a point where
there are no deaths from any particular
cause I mean if I said to you we have to
shut down the country until all deaths
from skydiving stopped you couldn't
actually do that because presumably
there
we'll be deaths from skydiving in a
country of 330 million people like the
the the attempt to shut down
conversation about this very thing like
when Trump says I'd love to open it up
by Easter and then people are like well
you know that's probably not right
instead of them people just saying well
maybe the time period isn't right but
that's a conversation we should start to
have it was how could he even discuss
this at this time does he just want it
does he want the Dow Jones Industrial
Average to rise the reference of human
life and I keep thinking to myself like
you have not even established at this
point that you or that your policies
over the course of a year until the
vaccine is developed are actually going
to save human life other than just
avoiding the overruns at the hospital so
let's say we avoid the overruns at the
hospitals which by the way it looks like
we are going to fairly successfully do
there may be some serious issues in in
New York hospitals but Cuomo said
yesterday that he thinks that the
ventilators will be sufficient we know
that the that the hospital beds are
already sufficient over there so let's
say that we do that now the question
becomes over the course of the next year
till when a vaccine is developed have
you actually lowered the amount of death
by keeping us all locked up or have you
just you know created a hard-line
position for which there is no
counterfactual because if you say we all
have to stay at home and we've saved
lives and I say well we won't have saved
lives if we do it like there's no way to
live in that counter universe whatever
is the policy is the policy that gets
implemented and it's very easy to argue
that if we had done it the other way
things would have been better or worse
you know I talked to Steven Moore on
Friday and he had just gotten out of a
meeting at the White House on this very
subject of how how are we going to open
this up when are we gonna open this up
he came out pretty pretty depressed
quite honestly but he came out and he
said to me that you know the point he
was trying to make was look you're going
to kill for every point of unemployment
that you raise the the average is about
10,000 people die so if we're at 30
percent unemployment you're killing many
more people then you would then would
have died with coronavirus you know
there comes this balance where if people
aren't working depression suicide
battery alcoholism all of this stuff
goes through the roof and this is what
the president was saying when he said
the cure
it'd be worse than the virus and we I
don't know where that is but nobody's
even allowed to talk about it you're
exactly right and in and it is all
because of this irrational hatred for
Donald Trump and politics yeah there is
this tendency that whenever there's a
crisis you've got to maximize that as
much as possible and and people in the
media who most of whom are retaining
their jobs unable to work from home
there does seem to be a vast disconnect
between the Twitter world where people
are hanging out and talking politics and
their little echo chambers and you know
Main Street America where people are
losing their jobs where they're having
their life streams destroyed you know I
think that we on the right we tend to
talk about you know if the economy goes
down then people are going to commit
suicide and and people are going to
engage in they're gonna die deaths of
despair and all of this but it's not
just that I mean you that lives are
ruined with how people die and and if
somebody has invested their life savings
to start a restaurant and then you shut
them down for a year without explaining
to them why you're shutting them down or
how they hope to come out of it and then
you expect everybody in America to
basically give up the basic freedom to
walk outside which is something that is
now happening right people are now being
pulled over on the street that is that
case in Pennsylvania the woman being
pulled over for the great sin of driving
in her car with her just by herself it
like there comes a point where I thought
freedom was actually one of the things
at issue here and I'm willing to you
know suspend the freedoms for a few
weeks here well you get the data but you
got to tell me when the data is coming
in and you got to tell me how you expect
to get that data in the first place it's
driving me up in absolute walls I've
asked the same people that you've asked
Glenn I mean I've been talking two to
three doctors a day on this stuff for
getting different estimates from
everybody nobody is even willing to lay
out a hard-and-fast path for how to do
this like you know Scott Gottlieb I
think does a good job in in trying to
lay this stuff out even he has been very
vague about what do you expect in terms
of testing and and contact tracing with
how do you expect that to happen
over the course of the next let's say
five months till we get to September's
when there's a second wave it's
sufficient to actually finish this stuff
like no one's being practical it's all
sloganeering I'm really concerned that
this is going to be handled so poorly
and there's gonna be such devastation
that when it does come back in the fall
you're gonna have
a real problem getting people back into
the houses you're gonna I mean you're
gonna ask me to shut down a second time
are you crazy you know the I talked to
people on the radio today that I asked
people who who's filing for business
loans and all these people calling in
they all said what a nightmare it was
how they couldn't the banks were trying
but they didn't know what any of the
rules were how you know they were
applying but they would have no idea
when that money would even come to them
this is these people are people who are
dreamers who worked their whole lives to
be able to save up did not have enough
money to even maybe they could keep
their business open for some sort of a
crisis for 45 days but that's that's the
limit 45 days they still have to meet
all of their bills they're seeing the
banks being bailed out immediately they
get their money immediately these small
businesses don't and they only get three
hundred and fifty five billion dollars
look I don't know about you Ben but I
didn't voluntarily closed anything down
my business is closed and shuttered and
nobody's working in my office because
the government told me not to do that
you know and maybe I would have done it
on my own maybe I wouldn't have but when
the government tells me you have to do
it and then I have to feel all the pain
the big guys get bailed out you told me
now I've lost my family business I've
lost all my dreams everything I worked
hard for and you're responsible I think
there is real real opportunity for
unrest to happen if Niagara doesn't
recognize the little person yeah I mean
well but you know president Trump I will
say the one thing that I think has been
keeping a lid on this at least from the
right
has been the fact that Trump is
constantly going out there and saying
things like I want to get the economy
back open because if I had the mildest
suspicions that the President of the
United States was actually using this as
a cover to promote giant government
programs I'd be a lot hotter right now
right the fact that the Donald Trump
obviously does not want to be in this
situation is definitely a help if if
Barack Obama were president right now
and
we're saying yeah we need to shut down
and also you know we could really use we
could use a few hundred million dollars
and a hundred billion dollars for
climate change here and maybe some job
programs some government job programs
there I would start thinking myself wait
a second
the never let a good crisis go to waste
mentality how bad is this thing actually
like I think that Trump's sort of
instinctive love for American business
is actually making me a little bit more
easy about the idea that at least
they're trying right at least they want
to get back there but again I want to
see some information on how we get back
there because I'm not seeing any
information whatsoever on how he gets it
to the points of contact I and I have to
tell you I am 100% I can't believe you
said this because today I was thinking
to myself if this were Barack Obama I
don't think I would be saying the same
thing because I wouldn't trust that
Barack Obama wanted to open small
business back up again that he wanted
that he wasn't trying to get something
where Donald Trump the one thing I can
say about Donald Trump that we all know
is true is he's capitalist there is no
way he wants all this stuff to burn down
to the ground it's bad and he knows it
he believes in the free market where
Barack Obama did not believe in the free
market he believed that you didn't build
this government built it Donald Trump
knows he's built it with his own hands
and his own sweat and he understands
that in America and I think you're right
him being president and him being a
capitalist a very well known capitalist
I don't think I would take it from
George W Bush either it's not just
Barack Obama I don't think I would have
taken it from George W Bush I know
Donald Trump at his core is a hardcore
capitalist that does not want this
shutdown a day longer so Glenn you know
looking forward to the 2020 election
obviously President Trump has not gotten
the sort of political balance you've
seen from other Western leaders and
that's predictable number one cuz the
media or the media but number two
because President Trump is not exactly a
Queen Elizabeth type he's not getting on
TV and telling us stiff-upper-lip gang
and and let's all let's all hold it
together how do you think that the 20/20
plays out you've got president Trump who
is volatile by temperament and then you
have Joe Biden who is presumably senile
so I will say I think the debates are
basically going to be the Swedish Chef
versus Chewbacca
they're not gonna be conducted in
English they're just gonna be conducted
in animalistic and odd languages and
dithering off into nowhere well what do
you think the how do you think this all
impacts 2020 I I first of all I don't
think it's gonna be Joe Biden I really
don't I don't know how they're gonna get
out of it but I don't think it's gonna
be Joe Biden I think it's good a V Cuomo
I really do I you know I hope I'm wrong
because Biden will be so easy to beat
but I think that there is something that
is happening that the media is not
paying attention to it all they always
make things worse and that is that they
have so discredited themselves with
China the coronavirus hydroxychloroquine
all of this stuff is just mounting up
and Donald Trump if you watch him at
five o'clock which I've been watching
him every day at five o'clock you see a
side of him that you don't see in the
media you don't see elsewhere and that
is him surrounded by really competent
people who respect him and he respects
them I mean I love these people who say
oh these guys are duping Donald Trump
really you don't think if he'd if he
didn't believe foul she you don't think
he'd be calling him Fathead foul Qi
right now and talking about how sure it
is and he would be able to see over the
podium you know he would so you see this
you see this executive standing there
running something very very complicated
and and holding his own and and no one
is looking at him like a cheese I can't
believe I have to be in a room with this
guy it looks like a well-oiled machine
and I think that goes a long way well
Glenn thanks so much for stopping by
always great to talk to you his book you
should check it out right now is arguing
with socialists and the argument at
least for the moment has been won
because bernie is is headed off to eat
some pudding at his third lake house
glenn really appreciate the time good to
talk to you great talking to you thanks
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content